the boulder police detectives worked
with the district attorney's office
to charge the suspect with ten counts of
murder in the first degree
and one count of attempted murder in the
first degree
the officer who exchanged gun fire
with the suspect has been put on
administrative leave
for our normal standard operating
procedures
the officer an 11-year old police
department veteran
was not injured during this incident
the firearm used by the suspect in king
supers on march 22
is a semi-automatic ruger ar
that gun was used in this incident
on wednesday the crime scene
personnel finished the king super slot
parking lot
and was able to successfully release
many of those vehicles to their rightful
owner
yesterday a team of investigators
including myself did a walk through of
the entire crime scene
which was very complex and obviously
very challenging
to not only myself but the investigative
team i just want to
say a few things about the community we
have received such an outpouring
of sorrow grief
uh and just it's just been extremely
um partnering for me to see how the
community supports
this police department and the other
victims
involved in this unbelievable incident
for that
i just want the community to know that
i'm very grateful
i also want to end on this because i
have never seen
this happen in my 30-year career
we have been able to successfully pull a
team of victims
advocates from across this region to
work not only with our police department
but all of the victims family and i
think that is so important because
this is just the beginning of this
journey and this will be at least a year
long's journey for these
victims families and the police involved
in this case
so i have never seen such a great
tool used in such a wonderful way and
for that
i'm extremely grateful as well and i
think we're going to answer some
questions after
district attorney michael doherty speaks
michael
thank you chief good morning everyone my
name is michael doherty i'm the district
attorney for boulder county
and on monday boulder suffered
devastating horrific
and traumatic attack to our community 10
people were killed
and many others were placed in grave
danger
our thoughts and prayers are with the
victims their loved ones and this
community during the difficult time
that we're all going through and we're
committed to ensuring that justice is
done
for each and every one of the victims
and for their loved ones
yesterday the defendant had his first
advisement in court
he was advised of his rights by the
judge and he's currently being held
without bond
and remains in custody next week
the court will announce the next court
date and will share that information
with the community as soon as the court
announces the court schedule
and at some point we'll have a hearing
it's called a proof evident presumption
great
hearing which in colorado is required by
law when someone's
being charged with first-degree murder
and held without bond
the court is allowed some time for that
hearing to take place so that the
defense attorneys
and the prosecutors have time to go
through all the video evidence
all the reports and all the discovery
and again that next court date will be
announced by state judicial
next week i do want to stress of course
the defendant has
the right the constitutional right to a
fair trial it's important that i stress
that every time i talk to the media and
community for a few reasons
first and foremost it's the right thing
for me to say and the right thing for us
to do
to ensure that he has a fair trial and
at the end of the trial he be held
fully responsible for his actions
second i want to make sure that we use
due caution
in talking about the case and the facts
of the case in order to protect this
right to a fair trial
but also to make sure that that trial
takes place here in boulder county
if we share too much about the facts or
the investigation it's possible we'll
see a motion by the defense
to move this trial to somewhere else in
the state of colorado
and i want to make sure that the people
of boulder have the opportunity
for this trial to be held and for
justice to be done
here in boulder county so you'll hear me
say every time i leave the press now the
charges have been filed
the defendant is presumed innocent
unless and until
he's proven guilty it will be a lengthy
court process in every murder
prosecution
the process takes at least a year for us
to complete i anticipate that that will
be the same
in this case so i share that with you as
i do with
the victims families and every homicide
case just so you
as a community have an understanding of
how long this process is going to go
forward
and we will as the chief highlight it
keep everyone updated throughout that
entire process i promise you that
i also emphasize it because over the
past
few days we've seen a tremendous
outpouring of support
for all the victims families and for the
community members devastated
by the attack that took place on monday
it's my hope and my request that that
support for the victims families
and for everyone impacted by this
horrific attack
continue all throughout the next few
months and until justice is done in this
case
and beyond they're going to need that
kind of help and support for years
so we've seen a tremendous outpouring of
support over the last few days we stand
now in front of a patrol car
that when we met with you on tuesday you
could see it clearly and now you see
today how many flowers are placed here
you go to king supers
you see the flowers and memorials that
have been set up there
that support for the victims my hope and
i certainly my intent
to continue that throughout this entire
process
the defendant's currently charged with
10 counts of murder in the first degree
he's charged with one count of attempted
murder in the first degree
additional charges of attempted murder
in the first degree
will be filed in the very near future
i will share with you that officers from
the boulder police department
and the university of colorado boulder
police department
so both boulder pd and cu boulder pd
responded
very very quickly to the report of shots
being fired at the king supers
immediately after responding they
charged into the store
their actions saved others other
civilians for being killed
they charged him to the store and
immediately faced a very significant
amount of gunfire
from the shooter who at first they were
unable to locate
and they put their lives at risk and
that'll be reflected in additional
attempted murder charges that will be
filed by the district attorney's office
the next couple weeks in addition i
anticipate other charges will be filed
in the weeks ahead and as that
information is finalized
make them that available to the media
and to the community
as a result of the actions of law
enforcement
there was significant danger to
civilians who were still in the
supermarket
and significant danger to the community
that danger ended because of the
response of law enforcement
the police chief mentioned that there's
an officer on administrative leave and
as she pointed out that standard
protocol
anytime we have an officer-involved
shooting in boulder county or anywhere
in the state of colorado there's a
certain protocol that we're required to
follow
that protocol involves a multi-agency
team of high-level detectives
investigators and district attorney
staff
assigned to investigate the officer's
use of
physical force or deadly physical force
against another
individual that protocol has been
followed since the evening of the
shooting
so by that i mean that multi-agency team
responded to the scene on monday night
and began their investigation they've
been investigating throughout the week
that multi-agency team in order to
maintain the integrity of the
investigation
does not include anyone from the boulder
police department it's investigators
from other agencies
the district attorney's office will
continue to oversee and support that
investigation
the investigators met just yesterday in
a different law enforcement facility
elsewhere here in boulder county
to brief everyone on the status of that
investigation and once it's determined
whether the officer was justified
in firing his weapon or not that
decision
and all the accompanying materials be
shared with the public and with the
community and available through the
district attorney's office
as in other mass tragedies and mass
shootings here
in colorado there's been tremendous
interagency assistance and cooperation i
can't stress
enough how many federal state and local
partners have come together
in response to this devastating attack
standing behind me today again we stand
shoulder to shoulder united ensuring
justice is done
for the victims their loved ones and the
boulder community are the fbi the u.s
attorney's office
the colorado bureau of investigation atf
and various law enforcement agencies and
partners from all around the metro
jurisdiction
as the chief highlighted we also have
victim advocates from all around the
metro jurisdiction
responding to help the victims families
in this case and connect with the many
people who are being impacted
by the shooter's actions on monday
there's a lot of work that remains to be
done this just happened on monday
but i will share with you that the
investigation is progressing rapidly
all the agencies involved and committed
to ensuring justice is done have been
working incredibly hard
day and night as they will throughout
the weekend to make sure that all the
information that can be learned about
the shooter
the victims the witnesses king supers
any connection between all of those
becomes known
and is available to the successful
prosecution of the offender
but i really do want to highlight
everyone including coroner emma hall and
her staff
for how hard they've been working since
this tragedy took place
on monday i will also thank the other
district attorneys from around the state
of colorado
and around the country who've reached
out to offer their support and
assistance
we greatly appreciate all the help and
assistance that we're receiving here in
boulder
from all around the state and all around
the united states
to the victims families
and to this community i promise you that
we work tirelessly to make sure that the
right thing happens
in that case that is my firm and solemn
commitment
and everyone in this building everyone
connected to this investigation shares
that determination
and focus we'd be happy to take a few
questions from members of the media now
thank you
thank you for your question i do
appreciate having the
assistance and expertise of the fbi as
i've talked about they have their
evidence recovery team at the scene
they're doing absolutely outstanding
work at the crime scene it's very large
scene
an answer to your question the fbi cbi
and all the law enforcement agents
involved are doing a deep dive into the
offender's background as well as the
background of everybody
involved in this incident victims
witnesses and so forth and at this point
we don't have any particular information
to share
in that regard uh we'll continue to look
into it and any connection we could find
will make available to the public once
we determine whether it's
accurate or not is there any indication
is there any indication
i don't have that information at this
point
it's a good question i think the victims
families and the community are desperate
to know the motive
we want to know the motive and that's
going to be the focus of all our efforts
going forward whether or not we're able
to determine it remains to be seen
still very early in the investigation
and that's going to remain a focus for
us going forward
can you explain more about that what
makes the scene so complex
sure just the um the vastness of the
scene
you're talking about a huge supermarket
obviously a huge parking lot numerous
vehicles um
it it's just one of the most complex
scenes i've ever i've ever worked
personally
and that's why i'm so grateful that the
fbi and their crime scene team is here
in the state cbi is here it would take
the boulder police department
weeks to get through a crime scene this
complex and so
thanks for your questions
as to why he chose this supermarket
from where he lived i i really do wish i
could
tell you that i just don't know and that
like the d.a said that's the focus now
of what we're trying to figure out it's
it'll be something haunting
for for all of us until we figure that
out and like
someone said sometimes you just don't
figure these things out
um but i am hoping that we will hey
can't talk to his attorneys or
disability can you answer this question
has the suspect um
any conversations between the defendant
and his council of course would be
privileged and protected we would not
have that information available to us
michael can you say anything or use any
insight about
any possible further review of uh
purchase a gun purchase that was made at
the eagle's nest
[Music]
as the chief indicated in her remarks uh
the suspect
is believed to use an ar-556 pistol that
was purchased legally in arvada colorado
he's also in possession of a nine
millimeter handgun and at this point in
time it's not believed that that was
used
during the incident the atf and fbi have
done
a tremendously thorough investigation
into
the guns that he had on him that day as
well as other firearms
that might be connected to him and that
investigation is ongoing
so i've spoken loud and clear over the
years since becoming district attorney
about the need for us to reduce gun
violence
in colorado and throughout the united
states and
at this point in time those discussions
and real action needs to continue
i'm going to remain very focused on this
case it is my primary focus
and today we stand just a few days after
this mass shooting
and i'm going to keep the victims and
their loved ones and the successful
prosecution of this case
as my focus
i do not i do not believe so at this
time obviously we're going to be
investigating this for weeks and weeks
but at this time
i don't have that information michael do
you have that i do have a
preliminary idea as to how many shots
were fired we're not ready to confirm
the number yet
it's a painstakingly thorough
investigation being conducted by the fbi
evidence recovery team
so to answer your question yes we do
know the number but we're not ready to
finalize that number and confirm that
it's accurate if you picture a
supermarket
picture all the shelves all the products
everything they're going through
every single shelf pulling everything
off the shelves looking in the walls and
that is going to continue throughout the
weekend
and once that crime scene is released
we'll be in a position to announce the
number of
bullets that were fired by the shooter
in this case
so more information on the firearms
would be released in the future but at
this point this is all going to say on
the firearms we're still conducting a
very thorough investigation with the
help from the atf and the fbi
on the firearms that he had on him that
day and other firearms within his
possession
thank you for your question i'm not
going to talk about any particular
witness what i would say
is if anybody out there has any
information i really encourage you to
contact the boulder police department or
the fbi tip line with information
and for witnesses who have been
cooperative with the investigation
we greatly appreciate that cooperation
it's going to allow us to ensure that
justice is done in this case and it's my
hope that all witnesses will cooperate
going forward
it was a grocery store in the middle of
the day so from your own experience
we've all been to the supermarket
that's how many people were there and
the defendant
but for the actions of law enforcement
and the quick thinking by a lot of the
people in the supermarket
this would have been much much worse in
terms of the number of victims
in answer to your question uh it's been
reported that there have been security
concerns around the defendant
that's not exactly uh unusual
necessarily i don't have any specific
information but
there have been other cases where there
might be a particular concern and the
individuals move to another facility and
that's all i have on that
particular question do you have any
information about
so your question is about a different
individual after this
mass shooting took place i don't have
any specific information on that at this
time
did you say attacked yeah did anyone cry
i couldn't hear you i'm sorry uh we're
still
going through all the evidence and
there's still a lot of witness
interviews to be conducted and video
evidence to be examined
i think we'll take one more question and
then wrap it up
shots were fired between the police and
the suspect yes and that's why there's a
police officer on administrative leave
now which again is our standard protocol
in boulder county
anytime an officer discharges his or her
firearm
the boulder police department puts that
individual on administrative leave and
we initiate our officer-involved
shooting protocol
to conduct a thorough investigation and
make sure that we determine whether the
discharge of the firearm was justified
or not
is that from an officer's shot
[Music]
so i appreciate your question i i'll
just leave it with this
that law enforcement's response saved
additional lives from being taken and
more detail will be shared in the weeks
ahead thank you so much for being here
today i'm going to turn it back over to
dion
they actually have another investigative
briefing to get to so they don't have
time for any more questions
um i do have a fact sheet with some of
the information talked about the number
of agencies
number of tips number of hours that that
investigators and detectives from all
these agencies have put in um
but this is all the information we have
for this morning's press conference
thank you
and i will email it as well i printed
out a number
you